i have to restart something okay great
all right uh welcome to another live
stream
of well from language design this is our
incremental language design
uh meeting and we have a variety of
topics
so first we have we are in the treetops
okay
so i think from our previous couple
discussions we generally like the
functionality here but we're having a
little bit of trouble with the naming
and just consistency with the other tree
functions in terms of
concept and
and right design so let's let's review
again what these do and do i have are
they runnable in the prototype build or
anything else no
okay so you have to demo them or send me
somewhere where i can remember there are
uh ref pages
okay
okay under
okay so let me try to remember what
these were let me try and describe them
in my words so ancestor tree
is the things that are above a given set
of nodes
in a tree
this is
the common ancestry
of those nodes is that correct
yep
well hold on it's the it's the union not
the intersection so it's not the common
ancestor
okay
it's the all ancestors
yes i mean common ancestor is another
concept that might be useful
correct
i think you can
do that just with looking at the
positions as lists
like you just want i see i see you
but you want to look at the list where
they agree
yeah
but i mean one possible name just for
that concept
would become an ancestor tree
would be
the what would that do would return this
sort of the tree up until
basically it would return the uh
uh in order for it it basically would
return a path tree up until
the split
is it a pulse tree
well if it's the ancestors and it's the
common ancestors then it has to be a
path doesn't it unless you're including
branches that don't lead to these nodes
also oh you're right it would have to be
a path yeah i mean
so say you give two positions
you'd have
a common ancestor and then two branches
well
that doesn't return a tree that returns
like uh
a particular
no i guess a node is a tree of some kind
but
yeah
i guess that that would be the common
ancestor tree function would be the the
tree whose
root is the lowest common ancestor
i see
it's like the greatest common ancestor
tree or something it's sort of like the
gcd or something
yes
i just want a tree just to see something
okay so for example of 13 and 19.
we would get up to the 20 here
we got from 29
right so 29 would be the least common
ancestor of those two
and you could give that as a tree and
what ancestor tree is doing is
doing the same thing but all the way up
to the root
tell me ancestor tree is giving the
whole thing up to the nine so it's
giving a path graph
down to this
is that right
and then it'll split
because 13 and 19 are in different
branches
will it also include like the one for
example no which is below the 13. okay
oh because it's not an answer so right i
think it's helpful to compare this with
uh tree delete
and delete so delete you give it
positions and you get rid of that
position and everything below it
but this is you give it some positions
and you keep that position and
everything above it
well i'm warming to the name ancestor
tree what was my objection to it last
time
that it sounded genealogical
but i i think lots of things have
genealogical terminology in trees
and it's the correct genealogical
concept yes
all right fine
so
um i don't think we discussed this
suggestion what do you think of the name
tree keep because the other
functions in this family are a tree and
then a verb
is one point and then the other point is
that this is a well-defined operation on
expressions not just trees so it might
be good to have a name that works in
both cases
what would it do reminds me of this
castle that's about all i know about
keeps
i can't remember what it is it's part of
the cost sense of keeping these
positions rather than deleting them
right and what's it going to do though
with the leaves that it is going to turn
them to null in the expression case
no it'll just delete
the arguments
oh i see
okay
what is the operation for an expression
it would be
so like if you said position one
then you would get rid of everything on
other branches from position one and you
would get rid of position one's children
so wait how is this different from
oh so it's basically the complement of
delete so with delete you'd say
right delete you'd say a position and it
would get rid of it this you say a
position it gets rid of everything but
that position i've never used this
function i've never wanted to use this
function
right so delete gets rid of the position
and its descendants and doesn't affect
other branches
ancestor tree keeps the position
gets rid of its descendants and gets rid
of other branches
yeah i mean i i'm not sure
i mean i sort of agree that i'm not sure
how useful the expression version would
be
but um
i don't see it as being that useful i i
think that i mean i haven't missed it in
in you know a third of a century as far
as i know
anybody else want to disagree with that
okay
i think ancestry is okay
all right what's tree top now tree top
is level
down to a certain level right it's
essentially a tree
it's a it's the analog of shallow
for a tree
yep
and again
it's the branches and the trunk it's not
the
treetop
what do you mean
that the tree top i mean if we're going
botanical oh because the top is where
the leaves are and this is the opposite
that's horrifying
and you had suggested last time
potentially calling treetop root tree
and giving it a one argument form
that just gives the the root
yes
i think that's reasonable
i mean okay what's the difference in
ancestor tree and root tree those those
are understandably different
an ancestor you have to give the thing
that it is
you know
that it is ancestoring if you understand
what i'm saying
the position
okay
can i ask a question when we have
a spanning tree
for a graph do we have a way of getting
it out as a tree
you can convert it
to a tree using graph tree
i see okay
sort of unfortunate that we have a
um
what is it called fine spanning tree
yes
sort of unfortunate that doesn't return
a tree
for for new
functions that return tree graphs after
we've started the trees project we've
started putting tree graph in the name
like dominator tree graph
is there a reason to have that function
not just dominator tree and then you can
use graph to get the graph of it
because you more often want it as a
graph
yeah it like lives in the graph world
kind of shape but in particular you
don't want a tree typically you
typically want a subpart of the graph
and i think the same is true here
three graphs and trees don't perfectly
round trip
i see
find a spanning tree graph that
minimizes the total distance between
you probably should change this
documentation now
and possibly it should have some other
argument that allows it or at least it
should have a good example that quickly
shows how to turn it into an actual tree
although i think in this case you're
more often wanting to kind of uh prune a
graph to through a subgraph so to speak
then you are to make a genuine tree
okay i'm happy with ancestry and root
tree
okay
okay we on to the next topic
yep
uh we have eduardo and gosha from
probability and statistics here we had
them look over a handful of promising at
least potentially interesting things
from the function repository and these
were a handful of things they pointed
out as being potentially useful and
reasonably implementable
is this accumulate but it's the mean
that one doesn't really float my boat
tremendously
yeah because you always just do
accumulate divided by range of length of
blah blah blah also
yeah but i just i i haven't needed to do
this very often i mean it's kind of like
you're either accumulating or you're
somehow taking the mean but this
accumulated mean i don't see very often
anybody am i missing something now
somebody speak up please i can imagine
it being something you want from time
series yeah who picked this out gosha
eduardo can you speak please
these are the suggestions from the
function repositories i know that but i
mean you picked them out so what was
your reason for picking this the reason
for it is that that this kind of what i
call running you know analytics so which
is kind of
going through the series or through the
time series are
you know used in
for example finance finance or financial
analytics so i run into the the you know
the the running what i call running
maximum or running minimum and so
running meme is very close to this idea
so my thinking here is that you know
this could potentially be
a part of what we call the time series
process
you know functionality where we can have
this this kind of an idea that you'll
specify a function and then you have a
resulting time series which is you know
so the the running minimum or the
running mean or the running maximum
and so that could potentially be i think
you know
part of you know time series processing
okay but what you're what you're
highlighting is this notion of something
which i've certainly wanted
which is a running
um
really what this is is some kind of
running map
correct max comma list for example
right and the and the thing is here that
we don't have a fixed length window so
it's not really the windowing what we
have with the moving map windowing
operation when the window has a constant
kind of length but here we see that the
window is right it's uncorked at the
beginning and it's just kind of what's
the engine it
yeah
i think that
fold could do this with supplied
um normally unfold the second argument
of the operation is just the next
element of the list but this is like
fold but you're taking
the the whole prefix of the list
not just the next element
often times that you you can implement
these things more efficiently with fold
anyway and not very difficult i mean
like the max there will work with fold
and it'll probably be more efficient
than if you do it
with this supplied way
mean for example is one where you want
to
you just want the whole list you don't
want to well but you if you if you have
supplied though you could ask for the
index and you multiply by the index
minus one add the new element and then
divide by the index right and that will
get you to mean right so you don't have
to recompute the whole thing in
quadratic or yeah i know what i was
saying is supplied could have a key that
just gives the whole list
so you don't have to sure but you don't
want to do that because you as as
i mean look okay the function running
you know i don't know if it's running
map or something like that
something like this is something i've
definitely wanted that is always show me
the maximum so far
did we
did we
put in position max what is the thing
find me the position of the maximum the
largest
no that's not the position of the
maximum
so so it would be largest with an index
exactly yeah
in what sense so let's take largest of
list arrow quotes index
yes
comma 1 or something
we should just record this because
this question has come up more than
several times now how do we do it come
on come on come on chroma
why doesn't that just take largest
okay but then
maybe maximal bite because you also have
maximal oh no wait till we don't that's
not the right thing oh yeah that is that
look i've wanted this function so many
times this position of the max
yes and we have discussed this several
times the problem is that what happens
if the max is repeated
so we are forced to have a little it's
like communist right
and that's why we ended up with with a
take version
yeah but
the next is arbitrary ordering or
i mean if we said
position
largest
of this
look i mean it's the same issue with as
commonest right
yes
and with position if you do position of
max it returns a list
sure
i mean the number of times i've had in
my code
you know
position of list comma max of list
i kind of think that we should have
something like um
uh
you know position largest
should it not be largest position or
something
there is something that's the smartest
function in the function repository yeah
it was like the first thing submitted
i think it should be position largest
and i think it should be basically
equivalent to this thing with the index
there
why is it called largest instead of max
is it because it uses order instead of
just numbers
or does this max even does max work with
order i'm actually sure
i'm suggesting max position which is the
thing that i would immediately think of
to call it
um
the problem is that max position
might be something quite different it
might be the you know if you have an
expression it's the maximum value of the
index
not the position of the maximum as in
length that that's a kind of weird no
that's weird okay forget that forget
that comment
look we've wanted this a million times
this this thing about
so we we need to and i take the point
that it's got to return a list because
there may be muc you know like with
communist
uh
max position largest
i mean we didn't call it take max
because
we did want to use order because it
isn't necessarily linearly you know for
example it might be uh strings or
something where we're using ordering of
strings
although i admit that that um
i i kind of favor position largest
we also have maximal buy
which is similar but doesn't have
indexing
so this is a family so it would have to
be position largest
smallest and potentially biased
yes i think so
i don't think that's terrible
okay but let's come back to running i
like these and i think we should try and
do them
but let's talk about running map
so john mcloone suggested something
similar
recently he has um
accumulated apply and withdrawal from
function
um ian you've got to send this in some
different form this is not going to be
useful here if i copy this it's just
going to look like garbage
what is this
ian hello
that pera fold is the variant of fold
that i was saying where it takes the
entire list up to that point
as a second argument
okay
like nest while can do it can take
a a
gulp size so to speak
okay
take
we have a fold while now
yes we do
well so the difference with with the
while functions is those are like giving
the
uh previous results and this is giving
the previous elements of the input
okay
okay but but um
that live stream is suggesting take
position by
i don't understand that one
oh i see that that's an alternative to
the
instead of having to say largest or
smallest why is that
make sense
position largest i prefer position
largest i think that's what it's saying
i want to talk about running map though
so what that's doing is it's always
giving for example the maximum so far
will be running map of max comma list
is that does that is that well defined
let's see a running map
right for a lot of functions f you would
want a custom implementation within
running map
i know but what is the general form of
running map
so running map of f comma list f comma
abc
would be
uh
right it would be f of
a f of
probably a in a list right
i see it's just f of a f b c
f a b c
no the second one is wrong
a b a b a b a b
okay
that's what it is so it's a sort of
triangular map
and the whole point is that there are
many forms of f for which this can be
done much more efficiently ian also
posted a function repository function
called accumulate apply
that
might be the same thing as parafold
um
it's more like running map because so
with map you have a one argument
function
right and so you're having f of list a f
of list a b this is an apply version
wait a minute applied to what i mean
this is this is like running apply and
what you have on the left is like
running map
and perifold is the same concept but
applied to fold
okay so hold on hold on running apply i
see so it's just a question whether it
provides the list
or whether it provides the uh individual
values
which is only pretty really relevant for
a flat function probably
you see what i'm saying
yeah
but numeric cases you would probably
want the list to avoid unpacking
yes but you might want something i mean
the question is for what values of f can
running map
do something much more efficient
so
it's some kind of it's not quite an item
potence thing but it's some kind of
property of f
right that allows you to add in another
one to fold in another element
for example in max in max it will be
able to reuse the previous value
well i know i know like christopher's
saying mean can do it but you have to
keep the count
as well
right
right
but the basic point is
there's a case where you don't have to
recompute because the new value what
properties does the function have to
have so that the new value with a it's
it's kind of a function that folds in
its next element
where it's
essentially their arguments comes from
folding
that right
i think it's just functions that you
could write with fold can be written
full it's kind of what you're saying
yes but once you can write it with fold
there's a much more efficient way to
compute this running map
than
often yes yeah
i put some code for running map in the
chat in terms of perifold
okay this
i wish we had a better way to do this
chat this is i mean i wish we could use
our own
chat thing where you don't end up with
these stupid things here
but yeah
i don't understand what the heck's that
x doing there
uh i didn't i didn't have the two
argument form of perifold no but i mean
we don't want that right i mean
that's just that's just this
so
i guess this is what this is showing
what i was saying map is a one argument
fold is a two argument
what
the operator f and fold takes two
arguments the operation yes obviously
yes obviously
i mean okay
i think running map is a useful function
i think it will be used with max a whole
lot
i think it's some
what what other functions will be i mean
i think mean is what um sandra is
commenting on here
um
um sanders commenting the word running
kind of suggests a little bit more like
the moving map
but i
don't think so i mean it's the running
maximum or something
you would normally say right
it's the maximum so far
i can imagine using it with the select
operation
find all the people who took the survey
that are under 30.
you know
show the time you know show it over time
how many people
i see i see so you're selecting you're
accumulating a selection
right of
okay so do we like the name running map
for that idea
so this will be running map of select
you know hash less than whatever hash
age less than 30 or something
right
onto the onto the data
right or maybe it's even
here
we would even say length
actually that wouldn't be that it would
be length do you like that better than
accumulated or cumulative
i don't think it is a cumulative i mean
it isn't that that isn't the concept
cumulative accumulate
well or is it
accumulate is like running map of total
yes right
okay other names for this
cumulative map
what about cumulative map
cumulative yeah yeah because you're
accumulating and you know
like what we have in the uh you know in
probability we have cumulative
probability function
which is
having similar effect that it's
increasing
and so it's stimulating the
probabilities up to that point so if you
have cumulative
map maybe just accumulating the maximum
up to this point or
accumulates the minimum let me tell you
i have about this name about the map
part of this
this thing here is being fed the whole
list that's not what happens in map
in other words if i say map of this
i'm doing that
do you get what i'm saying
yep yep
it's like mapping at the part numbers
instead of taking from the list and then
mapping on that
i didn't understand that comment but
it's basically taking versus part
what
so this is more i take
actually
it's like regular map you can think of
it as you you're applying to the parts
so like part one part two part three
whereas with this you're mapping to take
comma one take comma two take that
doesn't moving map do this and we call
that map
a moving map would be taking with part
comma span if we're thinking about it
like this yeah but the point is what
what um but it's still applied it's
still acting on the list
yeah
let's try and do this as cumulative map
but you could think about cumulative in
a sense that it accumulates the
arguments
right
yeah but either way i mean i think i
have been confused by moving map taking
a list
which it does right moving map
yes
so
i mean i think the thing is
oftentimes when you use moving map you
actually want block map
why is that two why is it giving lists
of three elements there
because it's range two
what does that mean
what do you mean it's range
look at that if you look at the
documentation the third argument has a
very complicated specification
basically you can tell it things like
what it's meant for is if you give it a
time series
and you want to be able to say something
like average the data that's one
one day radius from this point and is
that point in the center is it on the
left edge is it on the right edge
power windows overlapping etc
block map is the like straightforward
map of partition function
okay
i think we should have cumulative map
you can also specify this through the
argument to take the elements
what do you mean
when you do quantity of one comma
wait wait wait wait what are we talking
about moving map here or what are we
talking about
what are we talking about here
you're saying in in moving map so in the
moving map you can take the the events
i'm talking about moving mob okay
you can even specify the events but this
is designed for the for the for the
length of the window not for the number
of elements because you can have you
know irregularly sampled you know time
series you want to really for example go
over a week so it's your weekly you know
averages or something so that's why it's
it's the design itself takes the length
of the window not the number of elements
but there is a way to specify it through
the quantity events basically to to take
the the fixed amount but then the length
of course will be irrelevant so um so
this
in this way that's whatever the basic
point is moving map has an implicit can
deal with an x-coordinate so to speak
and
is taking chunks based on the
x-coordinate even though the
x-coordinate in the case of a list is
purely implicit
is that right i mean i don't understand
why it doesn't for if if you've just
given a list then not a time series i
don't really see why it doesn't just
take
the elements as being one two three four
et cetera
do you see what i'm saying
also if you give a list to the moving
map it it treat it as a as a
as a temporal data but that's crazy
right i mean it doesn't have it doesn't
have
time marks what if you give it x y pairs
what
right so i know if you give it x y pairs
right now it treats the x's is that the
time i think this is yet another example
of where like this temporal data thing
which i i
sincerely hope time series is getting
worked on it is isn't it
gosha
time series
yes yes it is
i'm sorry because
i mean so i'm saying temporal data but
in its time series
you know if you think about single list
it converts to the time series because
it's a single path and then it indexed
by integers so we kind of know that all
the all the elements in the list are
equally spaced
in that way
so that's all it's that that's kind of
how how this is understood if you give a
list to moving map okay but i don't
understand why moving map with comma one
gives two elements here
why isn't that
kind of in the units of because the the
distance because it's inclusive so you
need to you need
so i think what what gaussian is saying
is that this is a width so of a window
when you when you have this
so so these elements are assumed to be
separated so you're looking from your
your point into the left and to the
right
i see i see i see i see so basically you
landed on the comma
and you're saying how far do you go away
from the comma is that right well
they're moving i think i think really
it's you landed on the center
of of say element two and if you imagine
a window of size of width one on top of
element two the edge of that window will
touch you know elements one and three
and because it's inclusive then it it
it's only exactly
one is only going to the left here
or to the right to the right it's only
right inclusive
i think this is a bit confused i think
this deserves investigation
but not right so this is this is left
left open right closed
so you can
so the question is where's your window
placed and you also have a control over
you know how you how you kind of place
the window
right so that's the window position wp
os right so you can whether you want to
have it in the center and then you look
to the left to the right or you place on
the left end of your of your window and
then you just look forward so you look
to the right for example
i have to say to because in this case
when you have abcd's
you know
look look i'm sorry but in this case
i've got to be critical here this is
crazy the very first example shows a two
here and yet the things are in clumps of
three
so unless you explain in that example
what on earth it means to say a window
of length two when there are three
elements in it i don't get it
but i i think i i do get it so so the
first window of length but then the
second thing it's exactly the three
element i know but why did the first one
do what it did because it says over a
window of length two and yet i see three
elements there
because the the window goes from x1 to
x3 right so the the left border of the
window is x1 the left the right border
of the window
there needs to be more explanation in
this documentation
gosha you you can see that right i mean
this isn't working by this time it says
a window of length two and there are
three elements there we have to discuss
it for five minutes right the note
something that's wrong fifth note from
the bottom windows specification size or
size is equivalent to i think that's the
perhaps in some obscure sense when the
automatic means this kind of thing i
don't even understand what the automatic
means
can you gosha can you explain it i mean
i this may not be your functionality i
don't know do you not know this
functionality particularly well
well that's that's that's what joe says
it's the length and so the the
the only thing that maybe it's confusing
here because you're looking at the least
and so you don't really understand from
from looking at the list what how we
compute the length so the i think maybe
the improvement here is to you know to
introduce the time series with the
um with the unit um
distance between the the the values and
for the time step and then you can kind
of see how the windows are built because
each window of length tool have three
elements in it
right so you go from you know from from
x one to x two so okay i get this
two to x three it's step two so the
length would have the three elements in
the window i i understand
maybe you should say width two because
length sounds at the length of the list
yeah that's much better
right if if you change that language to
say
yeah i i see that
yes
and then windows specification with the
size up above okay all right so i think
we all understand now width two means
the distance from
the position specification of the first
thing to the position specification of
the last thing is two
but that just has to be better explained
okay we're off that topic
so i think cumulative map is a good name
for this thing
let's try to investigate implementing it
okay anything further to say about this
together with
um
position largest position smallest etc
make sense
any objections
okay let's move on
okay bin lists by
i mean this tends to me to seem like it
makes sense i
mean then let's buy
yes i mean this obviously makes sense
because ordinarily when we say bin lists
i mean i hope we don't have to and i
don't think we are introducing sort of a
bi version of every function i don't
think that we are i'm not too worried
about that
does this also be introduced as as in
the arguments of of bin lists like i
think there's some examples down there
where you know you have a rule or
something
well what
well i i'm not sure what if this is a
proposal or or what but like bin lists
of data arrows string maybe you could do
that instead of having a buy function
yeah i think that was the central
question is is this sufficiently
important to have a standalone function
or does it make sense to be an existing
an extension of existing i think it
should be its own function i think the
by family is easy to remember
i generally don't love the arrow
notation to change
functionality there yeah i think it's i
think that's a you know a corner case
one okay
we are really these are sander functions
and sanders is uh
uploading his functions as he should
um
uh
let's see
what is the second
that is the bin specification
oh boy what do we do with the structure
of the arguments here
to understand my question
yes
so what do we do with take largest and
take largest buy
in that front
oops
so we inserted the function second
so there is the same question with
respect to the yes yes
right because the buy form by the time
you're using buy you know you have a
function
yes
and is there a default
let's see just take largest buy have a
have a operator form
yes it was too much it does
does bin lists have an operator form
probably not
no it can't
um
what is the
uh
is there a two argument version of bin
list spy
is that a meaningful thing
is there a okay hold on
is there a count
are we looking at it too
argument form
this should be more like group by when
no yeah i mean i would think that the it
being by
a by function would potentially be at
odds as
having a bin specification
because they're they're kind of two
different approaches to the binning
process right that
when we have bin specifications that say
i want n bins or i want
you know bins of length y it's
implicitly changing the the function
that collects them into bins
it's changing i mean this is you take
things like the strings here
and you are binning them actually what
is the relationship between this and
group by
this is the list form instead of the
association form
but since you don't have the keys it
needs to be dense
right you need to include all those
empty lists in this example
i see which is useful
it's useful yeah you need the one and
the ten in the inputs and you need the
empty listening outputs because you
don't have keys
group by has keys so it can be
you don't need to specify those inputs
yeah and it can be sparse yeah
okay well i think makes sense
let's investigate try and implement
makes sense
yep
objections okay
so this last one is just a note because
it's in related functionality but
we have the old anova package there's
functionality there that would be
potentially useful um it's not really a
one-off
function repo or
my understanding from talking a little
bit with gosha and getting a little
feedback from goshen eduardo is that
it's not a
super simple or small project to set up
anova functionality
well no i mean look
we built the sonova stuff at a time when
our ability to represent
sort of named objects and things was
much lower than it is today with
associations and data sets and so on
right
question if we were going to invent
anova in the land of data sets
would we be able to make an anova data
set from a data set so to speak
does that make sense
is that concept a reasonable one
eduardo gosha please
go show your stuff i don't know
i mean i don't know
how do we what what is our current anova
i mean right now we have
only this package is that correct
or do we have another way to just
okay so i'm going to make the hypothesis
that if you gave this anova table as a
data set
with named you know string names for
these things that that would be useful
you see what i'm saying
yeah like are we pretty i guess
no no no no i'm
look the whole point is how do you use
the elements here
do you get what i'm saying they're very
hard to use here i don't even know what
the structure is
do you know what it is
did you understand my question
by the way but that's a bug somebody
needs to note that that doesn't show
preview there
i got that
okay
okay do you know about this function
gosha eduardo either of you know about
this function
are you muted or are you i don't
understand are you here are you not here
can you respond to that question please
i'm here but i'm having i'm having a
connection issues and i didn't correctly
understand what you were asking
okay
i was also having connection issues and
i just came
okay all right well that explains why
you want here
otherwise i i okay
okay
i'm asking this function do you
understand function
what is this object what is this output
for example
okay look if you have if you have a
connection problem we can't we can't
continue this right now we have to do it
another time
can you hear me or not
yes
okay so are you going to respond or not
i mean i'm i'm trying to i have a really
hard time right now okay okay fine all
right okay so let's let's pick this up
another time
okay so this is looks like
some crazy crazy stuff i think it's
table form or something under the hood
it's not right so what i'm saying is you
guys should think about and next time
come back with a proposal that it
involves an anova function that returns
a data set
okay
i think if you guys are if if the
statistics team is is
unconnected so to speak let's not go
over these other things right now we're
going to run out of time anyway so let's
move to these other other topics and
we'll bring those back
okay until
so until is a
variant of while that we talked about
earlier in the year we have an
implementation of it we just have
documentation we want to review before
okay evaluates body then test
possibly until test first gives true
why do we need that one argument form is
that a good idea or should we just leave
that out
it just follows what wild does
it's a while so we imitated it
okay
i don't know is it a good idea it's not
obvious that's a good idea
it is not compulsory it's just again
it's just consistency with wire
okay this looks okay to me anybody
object to this
no no yeah
all right i don't want to take this
right now because this is
unless unless there's an easy way to
discuss this
what is this
so so this is an example i i talked to
andrew ewell who's one of our customers
who watched one of our previous
discussions about having a general way
to generate operator applied or to
quickly generate operator forms and he
mentioned this is
effectively
why isn't the start at star
isn't the sat star
what what is this doing i don't
understand what this does what does this
mean
yeah so this is fee yeah this is feeding
range into the first argument of list
plot oh absolutely it's at star plus
operator applied or something right no
it's even more than that it's even
weirder never mind
because i think it's taking over the
arguments of list log plot because this
thing here has to not evaluate it it's
going to get really weird right it it's
complicated implement i mean that's why
this example has a hold rest in there
because we don't want
the list log plot
evaluating and giving
i think this is a lot easier if the code
doesn't mean anything
we can look at this again but i'm not
optimistic
let's look at this which i think is a
rather straightforward
idea
i mean maybe the real thing would be to
have some sort of
syntax for operator applied
although i'm not sure that
you know
i'm not sure it deserves it i mean i
think that this this notion of you've
got a symbolic function and you're going
to spray
uh i mean i think it also relates
actually to this thing here
right these two discussions are kind of
interrelated but they've branched a bit
right so okay so this is this form so
the only question is given that people
in the modern world you know
33 years ago
35 years ago when we first designed
function
uh
well 42 years ago when i first designed
the analog of this in smp
which had some horrible misfeatures
you know lambdas were an extremely
obscure idea
uh now they're much better known
and so the question is purely a
syntactic question
you know we have a form of function
right now which is this very beautiful
thing which i i love using when you know
the only thing i don't like about it is
that i have to parenthesize it so much
but i love this thing i mean i think in
in cases like nest it's terrific
okay so the question is
is there a value in having something
which is a lambda
you know something which is lambda of x
uh you know x squared as yet another
form for function
and i would argue it's not completely
crazy to do that
comments from people
i like it um
another question with that form is could
you have
a syntax for the three argument form a
function similar to for all
you mean the one with attributes and
things yeah so and for all you can say
for all x comma then have conditions on
the x which is a little different than
specifying attributes but maybe that
could be like lambda x comma hold first
well except that we're going to need in
this case here we would definitely need
a lambda x comma y here
or list x y yeah
but i mean
this thing is going to have to be
parenthesized in this case isn't it
christopher what do you think of this
i think it's it's it's interesting i
mean my only
the only complaint would maybe just be
that
you know having yet another syntax for
function could be confusing
and people won't know which one they
should
yeah but some people will will pick the
one they like i mean
and it does answer the question are
there lambdas
yeah edmund is commenting it's only
worth doing another form if it solves
parenthesis problems if it solves
another type of parenthesis problem
i i partly agree with that but for
example this form i really love it for
nest it's just very clear piece of code
actually how does um
how does the the fancy arrow notation
work with rule
like what's the precedence yeah that's a
good question
i actually don't know
um
no not well
i mean i think we were pretty
constrained in the precedence for this
thing
it's not obvious that that is a bad way
to write something i mean i understand
it has to be parenthesized but it's a
little less obscure to parenthesize to
have to parenthesize that and have to
parenthesize the thing with the
ampersand
it's much less obvious in this case it's
kind of obvious you might have to print
the size in the case c arrow
a plus hash
ampersand it's much less obvious that
would have to be parenthesized
i mean that feels like a much more
superfluous parenthesization
but okay so what would maybe we can
study what the precedence of lambda
could be
okay yeah that's something that i had
made a bit of a mention of but he's not
here today um
okay
um
another question would be if there's a
way of if there's an escification of it
yes that is a good question
what would its acidified form be it
would have to be some horrifying
um
you know thing like that
yeah
i guess it looks like a little like an
uppercase lambda
it does what do other that there's some
there's some other languages that have
haskell just uses a backslash that's
more horrifying than one could possibly
imagine
uh
i mean could we in fact use this
i'm not sure we have the right people
here to say for certain i mean what if
you're dividing by a special character
isn't the ascii form of special
characters start with uh
yeah like a new line for example but i
don't think you can have a new line
in
see it's not it's true having having
backslash means something
you know
could lead to immense
confusion
well okay so i mean it would have to be
some kind of
uh
like the asciifation of all of our
special characters is backslash open
bracket right yes right so you know and
you constrain those values and then
divide things by them
right i mean the problem is that a
lambda a plane lambda
i mean i guess plane pi means something
i'm not sure that it would
break it i mean that's like i don't
think it would break anything to have
plain lambda hell i don't know well no
it would just use again
because
that thing as a pure symbol
um
is
uh you know lambda as a pure symbol
is something we absolutely have right
now so we can't use that we can't use
pure lambda
right
uh
so it would have to be a stylized lambda
which is okay
which argues for an occupied form that
can be
uh
sort of you know like like happens with
with this which i like very much i mean
that asciified form which is vertical
bar dash greater than you know i it's
easy to remember and
you know i i don't know how people learn
to type it having seen just this
um
well perhaps we can think about this
okay think about the precedence and
think about the acidification of it
i mean you know it's a little bit less
attractive to asciify it when it has to
have subscripts
because i don't think you can avoid the
subscripts unless you have
something like
you know lambda
hash plus one
which and i don't know again print you
know
precedence is what we have to figure out
is there a reasonable place where we can
for example does this grab the hash plus
one or not i can't really imagine how it
could grab the hash plus one
people comment on that
yeah i'm not as familiar with like the
match fix system and the other um
okay we have to look up
yeah
all right i think it's time to wrap up
here
um
[Music]
um
great all right well thanks everybody
for
everything and
talk to you all soon